[Music]
poor lady mechanic one big family one
[ __ ] sister holds and we love our hands
to be dirty our fingers to be deadly we
are together and we are fixing cast
around the world all right
make sure you do you have your homework
done I need to see the papacy all right
my name is Sandra I won't bow from the
first female mechanic in Nigeria the
founder of the lady mechanic initiative
I've been a mechanic for text two years
and I've been running my own garage for
23 years now so that is the way it works
the lady mechanic initiative is working
with the vulnerable group the estimation
sex workers this code dropouts marriage
we may want to acquire a skill they are
like there's no more help in my life I
said so then you know what you have got
a lot of horrible to have to do down I
mean Aria she has five children and
she's a mechanic amazing because they
are vulnerable they don't have money
therefore poor background so they don't
pay to learn and we draw this from the
funders from the speediest I paint pay
for the election overall I'm a trainee
is just free of charge you want to be
able to help other women as well now
we've been able to empower graduated by
thousand female mechanics in Nigeria in
fact it
I mean the first women mechanic a little
bit of horses may I've been there from
generation to generation
fixing cars when I came me it was like
excuse me are you okay or you need to
see a doctor but no I knew what I was
doing but for me to become the first
female mechanic in Nigeria had to work
five times other that the way they may
walk to prove myself many more they
don't know me by my name is lady
mechanic everywhere I go now a lot of
guests wants to come to Nigeria to blame
artifice cars is the best job in the
world for any woman I see I'm Erik Mason
I'm a mother and I'm a transgender guy
Koree is my 15 year old transgender
daughter I started transitioning almost
two years ago and Corey started
transitioning almost five years ago I've
always known that I was different
I've always known that I'm not the
normal boy I was never like tapi I was
always negative and when I first put on
some makeup I was like
[Music]
my family is made up of me my husband
and my five children I waited until Cory
was completely through her transition
before I came out myself it was really
hard keeping that secret from my family
especially for my husband but at the
time I just knew I had to focus on my
child
I've been boy since fifth grade and
still getting bald sometimes when kids
said I should go and kill myself because
that I was different when my mama came
out I was like I'm not alone anymore we
can actually understand what we're going
through with each other we can you know
talk to each other for having a bad day
me supporting Cory is in my opinion what
you're supposed to do as a parent you're
supposed to support your children no
matter what so I don't feel like I did
anything special I didn't I just love my
kid I love my kid no matter what she
looks like no matter who she wants to be
we are stronger as a family I think
anytime you are living your authentic
self and you are living your truth it
makes you a better person overall it
makes you a better parent it makes you a
better spouse my family is everything we
fight we laugh we cry we're a typical
family we just look a little different
that's it it's all boiled down to
[Music]
you
[Music]
my mom is amazing person yeah Lilith we
all agree we carry new father
jenika Shenyang in Rosario Vargas are a
mother and daughter separated by a
border one living in San Diego and the
other in Mexico
I came from Mexico 2006 because I want
to get another opportunities for my kids
cuando se bueno en scène O'Meara's Teddy
de penser came Ibis air brave de la
Volpe reverse
I don't have the permission to cross the
border the line from the last
year-and-a-half I see my mom to the
fence at the sight of a by National Park
in San Diego the u.s. Border Patrol
allows families to meet on the weekends
loved ones enter the park and walk
directly up to the border a steel fence
this gives families on both sides a rare
opportunity to see and speak to each
other
no veo el Circo a part a chimera
tristeza made Alegria porque voy a vera
mija you know you're gonna see your mom
you're gonna see your family but the
fence and they have a tiny holes in my
mom's I'm chance put the finger in the
tiny hole I just a little touch it just
touch it
or sometimes I give you a kiss
esta muy cerca a la vez tan lejos the
merciful my life in sympathy with the
qur'an mucho on April 30th for the third
time ever authorities agree to open the
door allowing select families a brief
moment to embrace each of them will only
have three minutes
boys are not come with my ass until our
momento take it up with our Asajj they
get wasted who died right now I feel so
happy because I'm waiting I'm waiting so
much this moment
[Music]
[Music]
I feel incredible she was so happy she
was so sweet with me she tell me I love
you mommy I love you so much I love you
love you
[Applause]
[Music]
this is not a landfill
this was verse of a beach in Mumbai
India a little over three years ago it
was covered in over 6,000 tons of trash
after what the United Nations called the
world's largest beach cleanup
this is Versa Beach today it was the
movement started and led by one man
afros Shah my name is Arash and a lawyer
by profession and I love oceans in
October of 2015 first of a beach was
little more than a dumping ground on the
west coast of Mumbai there are five and
a half feet of plastic and when you see
so much plastic objective was to the
ocean it's clear it's very scary we have
devastated the health of her ocean in
garbage pileup either on land or an
ocean is a big issue not only in India
world or so afros took matters into his
own hands he started picking up the
trash himself I have spent my childhood
here you know I used to play her and the
beaches to be very very clean for me it
was purely simple it had to be my
personal journey then I told myself will
be difficult personal man to do it so I
said might not take this personal
journey to others i provoked others to
join him and eventually did journey
since 2015 every weekend hundreds of
volunteers join afros to pick up the
trash that has been strewn along a
two-mile stretch of the beach and the
volunteer work continues today we have
been cleaning for past 112 weeks now and
it's almost 9 million kgs of plastic and
filters from the Ocean Beach cleaning is
one of the biggest preventive action to
prevent this plastic going into the deep
sea this is minimum we can do since the
use of trucks bulldozers buckets
whatever people can use the beach has
slowly been picked up
but the issue is more than just the
beach it's about the mindset of people
so apart from the beach cleanup afros
also works with local communities to
help educate them on recycling and
proper trash disposal we go to coastal
communities where you know the littering
happens talking to them I go to people's
garbage
I tell them show me then I tell them how
to segregate how to handle plastic this
is the first Creek which is entering
into the ocean from here I'm proud that
I'm connecting with people and I'm
connecting in nature that gets a very
big sense of pride in my heart you know
this problem of pollution is created by
us they've lost a sense of belonging to
the our planet into our ocean a lot of
people ask me a phrase how long you
gonna clean the day we say that this
ocean is mine and it has to be [ __ ] and
span will not ask this question in fact
we'll go and provoke others to do what
I'm doing we are in for a long haul and
every citizen on this planet must be in
for a long haul start doing a bit
[Music]
[Music]
particular capacity purple on to access
transport a she-wolf AHA traditionally
Karnas educator on typical religious
african-americans as well to determine
the man
Tara masala and that repeated and
transfer fancy la miseria Knox but
Ponder's proudly to see a o TT Pacifica
and transform makea da Cunha give Apple
smokey that damn kita priori - Brian I
took a drive shaft on de Monte bubble
New Guinea on capacitor American
territory fully mouth + / 22 - Patrick
well-run young recoup our losses young
Brazil Gotama police as Ibaka
Amanda Mallya is the alanya deploy
across often is agata most efficiency
identification of banyan aware that the
truth - thump up caputo annularis
capacity - ketta motor origination the
exacto single sip and go tomorrow - in
satellite even but will check window for
0 dad
blew it defied approach Allah Rakha it's
a visa program a career depression you
know Catania profiteer strategies and
anther Breaka kumano y otros Polan lacki
katana Bromberg and again in finances
our image the colonial warriors
awakening
[Music]
ask AHIMA he wide are you mean hombre
Hinata Flores tango deceasing sannyas so
you can't and a yes titrate another
preserve our el idioma k2l Quechua is
needy OMA la nostra Center Posadas los
incas y también Nostra Kultura yes
idioma es esta perdido en el peru let
him take in the way and I'll catch a
kuhmo I will similarly the poor essa the
discrimination see Sofia del Quechua
time in history our propensity is
appreciated in Peru you come and say a
contender continuously modernist in
Quechua my own mental prowess her
Venezuelan couch our lope and establish
know your nature
ain't nothing new to me
let's go see this game instead of saying
Quechua a friend of Michael Jackson's in
there is a kid
[Music]
in a concerned a Michael Jackson the way
you make me feel so Matthew medium
babysitter if we can't get a lock on
fair so you know cameo safe and more
open setting and Stadium the part I lost
colonies gustaría in Sinhala personas a
get kanessa breakage
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]